it's seen as the final frontier of
global cooperation after the cold war
but russia has decided to pull out of
the international space station is it
even possible and what will be the
impact on future space exploration and
research
this is inside storm
[Music]
hello welcome to the programme i'm
bernard smith
the international space station has been
a symbol of cooperation between cold war
and space rivals for more than 20 years
american astronauts and russian
cosmonauts collaborated despite the
challenges of their nation's
relationship here on earth but even the
iss could not escape the tensions
created by the war in ukraine russia
says it will withdraw from the programme
after 2024 and launch its own similar
space station
nasa called the announcement a surprise
but it's unclear how moscow can untangle
itself from the project it also involves
astronauts from canada europe and japan
working closely together
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
first this report by vincent mona
the future of this beacon of
international cooperation may be in
doubt
when the war in ukraine prompted the
west to sever nearly all ties with
russia the international space station
was one of the few exceptions
three two one now after more than 20
years of partnership russia says it's
pulling out
of course we will fulfill all our
obligations to our partners but the
decision to leave after 2024 has been
taken i think that by that time we will
begin to form a russian orbital station
and lift off
to many this move was a surprise
nasa and the russian space agency had
only just signed a new agreement to
ferry astronauts to the station in may
the head of the european space agency
said cutting ties with russia on the iss
was technically impossible
both sides are responsible for different
technologies on the station and neither
is trained to operate the others without
assistance
it's going to cause problems um the the
russian sort of side of things is in
charge of several key systems onboard
the international space station um
probably one of the most key ones is its
propulsion system so that's the thing
that stops it from uh because it it's
just about in earth's atmosphere and
over time its orbit does slowly degrade
and it gets closer and occasionally it
needs to get it's all bit boosted up
again and the russian segment is
responsible for doing that first through
the hatch is denise matvian since the
war in ukraine broke out even life in
space hasn't gone untouched by the
politics of earth
in april questions were asked about the
russian crew's choice of spacesuit which
matched the colors of the ukrainian flag
they denied any hidden messages but many
saw it as a protest against russia's war
in july the russian crew made a much
clearer political statement
they posed for photos with the flags of
luhansk and donetsk
two russian-backed breakaway regions in
eastern ukraine it's unfortunate that uh
the politics on the ground have now
reached up into space before the iss was
the one common ground that we had where
uh you know it was in everyone's
interest that at work and we never
neither side use the iss for
these kinds of political posturings for
events on the ground
the iss was first established back in
1998.
research on the station has led to
breakthroughs in battling cancer
alzheimer's and heart disease
monitoring natural disasters from space
has also helped relief efforts here on
earth
but with russia and china now planning
to complete their own space stations in
the coming years a period of space
cooperation may be giving way to a new
era of space competition
vinton molyneux al jazeera
now this news has caught many by
surprise because nasa and russia space
agency had just struck a deal two weeks
ago to fly each other's astronauts to
the iss cooperation between russia and
the u.s had appeared relatively unharmed
by the ukraine war until now
the european space agency had already
ended its collaboration with russia's
space agency
and moscow has stopped launches of its
soyuz spacecraft from a european launch
site in french guiana
let's bring in our guests in moscow we
have pavel falconhauer a defense and
military analyst in orlando florida amy
thompson a science journalist and
contributor to space.com and in london
francisco diego a lecturer at the
department of physics and astronomy at
university college london welcome to you
all
pavel uh first of all for you is this
ukraine related is it political russia
pulling out of the iss
uh well it's clearly ukraine connected
because after the conflict there began
uh sanctions were imposed in on russia
by the west and some of them these
sanctions are against
parts of the ros cosmos the state
space corporation
russia has already said that it will
continue
with the cooperation on the space
station if these sanctions will be
lifted they have not been lifted
so that means russia is right now kind
of saying that okay we're going to boot
the whole project since it right now is
not bringing russia much any money
anymore
and but this does not actually mean that
this is the end of the issue
i should emphasize that i think there's
going there's of course some time left
to i don't know 25 and there's time for
some bargaining so if uh there russia
with the most likely say there actually
there are actually different ways in
russia could quit
uh quit fully uh so the station has to
go down into the ocean pacific ocean or
kind of continue on a commercial basis
to cooperate to some extent to keep it
running till 30
or uh russia would be demanding some
sanctions relief okay so it's not yet
closed issue all right so amy as pavel
says there it's not over yet is from the
american side is this viewed as bluster
is there hope that it's bluster
yes so um russia said that they were
going to pull out after 2024.
there was a report that came out talking
to one of their lead flight directors
that was discussing the their version of
the space station that would the first
pieces
would launch maybe around 2028 so from
nasa's standpoint nasa has said that
they would like to operate the space
station until 2030 but it is also at the
same time preparing some commercial
partners to launch sort of mini space
stations i think axiom has one
blue origin has an orbital reef that
they're partnering with several other
agencies that they want to launch so
this notion of having multiple stations
is probably something that's going to be
happening around the same time that
russia wants to do their own so
i definitely think that there is room
for negotiation all right we'll touch on
the commercial operators in space a
little bit later uh francisco though
what would it mean to the iss to the
operation the practical operation of it
if russia did withdraw
uh it's going to be i think very
difficult
the um you cannot divide the
international space station that easy
the russian module is as we saw in your
in your uh introduction is responsible
for the movement of the space station
for keeping putting in orbit and it has
the power to do that and that is control
from moscow i understand
so how these things are going to be
sorted out is very difficult to imagine
and i hope that pavel said i hope that
these negotiations are going to to take
some kind of more constructive approach
amy help us understand practically how
the two segments of of the station are
interdependent on each other and rely on
the russians and the americans operating
them
yes so um as
stated the russian side provides
propulsion so it essentially keeps the
iss in orbit
currently there is not
a u.s vehicle that is capable of doing
that but i'm sure that that is something
that nasa
and its partners are
you know thinking about especially after
the announcement yesterday and then the
usi provides power it's got the solar
panels so they they work together you
can't have one side without the other
side
pavel who's holding all all the cards if
you say there might be a potential for
uh negotiation who needs this more the
americans or all the russians
uh well both like we both need it
need the station though the russian
interest has waned the bit
uh uh of course during the
for quite a long time since the shuttles
stopped to fly
russia had a monopoly to bring
astronauts and cosmonauts aboard
the space station and so russia was
earning a lot of money
hundreds of millions of dollars a year i
mean the one trip for one person was
up to 70 million dollars
so that was bringing a lot of cash to
ross cosmos that has right now ended
their beef flights on russian soyuz
ships for americans but that will not be
for money much that will be exchanging
exchange for russians flying on american
ships so it stopped to be a money cow
the space station for ross cosmos and so
now they say oh they're not that much
interested in continuing to maintain
this aging station
so they hope that they maybe believe
that uh right they have the americans
need it more and so russia can wager for
that and get something in return for
still keeping it flying for five years
up to 30. okay francisco
there's an operational importance to
having integrated crews on board i read
i understand what are what are the risks
they've got this crew swap agreement
where
american crews can fly in on a russian
rocket russians can fly in on spacex
what if these what is the importance of
having these integrated crews on the on
the iss
well it is very important that is a very
basic principle of international space
station and it is very sad that this is
happening i would like to see more
cooperation i would like to see a space
exploration
less competition more collaboration this
is not the way to go into space this is
not the way we have explored our own
planet and look at the state of the
planet now as a result of what we have
done in the last few centuries are you
going to do the same in space i think we
have this opportunity this challenge now
to really reset our mindset and reset it
and then put more collaboration and more
peaceful collaboration and explore the
moon as humanity not as a single country
or as a single company i hope we have we
can achieve that
well amy as francisco is hinting at that
there's symbolic importance of having
integrated crews as well as well as
practical what are those practical
importances of having them uh integrated
crews on board
well
it's good to have those you know because
you have each program has something
different that they work on you know as
far as science and and other things like
that so they bring that into them by
having crews you know and it's just
really um like he said symbolic it's
it's
this is what we want to see we want to
see cooperation because the space
station is
literally like the crown jewel of
humanity like this is what happens when
everyone works together
and
we are all capable of achieving great
things so we need this cooperation
pavel you've been suggesting that a lot
of this has come down to dollars in the
end to cash
could the russians build their own space
station has been hinted at would they
would they want to could they afford to
do it
um well some kind of uh station mosque
will appear it will take time
again the the station that's being right
now planned will be very different
from the present
a space station it will be flying higher
on a different orbit much higher
that means it won't have a permanent
crew
the crews will be visiting so it will be
much smaller
for sure with visiting crews
uh it's not will be like the present low
orbit space station which is very
enormous
500 tons of metal and equipment flying
there such a thing will most likely
never again appear anytime soon in orbit
around earth
amy are there alternative partners for
nasa for the americans the europeans
maybe maybe or is it the russians or no
one
um no so
there's 15 different international
partners i mean russia is one of them so
when they pull out there's still 14
other countries including the us that
are you know that work together to make
the international space station so nasa
would probably lean on on those partners
a little bit more
um if russia pulled out
okay and francisco the station the
station is due to retired in 2031.
what happens to it
then
well it will be a continual control
descent it will be the orbit and then
we'll it will land somewhere in the
pacific ocean
as will be the the hubble space
telescope
at some point as well
so it will be the orbit that's what
happens when you are in low earth orbit
you are
just reduce the speed and then in a very
controlled way just just bring it down
and we must remember also that china is
completing their own space station this
year and that's another component here
another country that was not allowed to
join in the international space station
they went their own way and they are
building their own uh in record time
actually their own space station as well
so um i hope as i said before that all
this collaboration comes more close
together because uh space exploration is
very forgiving it's very it's very uh
extremely dangerous you need
international collaboration to deal with
emergencies to deal with
many enormous challenges and it will be
good to have the expertise from
different
from different
scientific and technological groups
working together
i wanted to move on to to china actually
and and pavel again could russia
realistically move on to cooperate more
with china's space programme very
ambitious china's supposed to be ahead
of russia now technologically in space
uh well most likely not ahead
technologically
but
actually clearly ahead in finances so
they are building it swiftly they have
more money to spend technologically most
likely russia and china are more or less
on par
maybe in
rocket technology russia is at least if
not ahead well it's maybe has some kind
of headway there
cooperation and space between russia and
china there has been a lot talked about
it
uh in recent years it's not really that
easy to happen
the chinese have their own space station
it won't be really uh
compatible with the russian one
but there can be kind of visits of
chinese going on to the russian station
of russians going on to the chinese
station i think that's possible that
would be symbolic
but i don't think that the two pro
countries are going to actually merge
or build a joint project like the
international space station which
appeared in the hay year as of after the
end of the cold war when it seemed that
conflict and war
in europe would be totally impossible
well now in a different very different
age and cooperation in space is going to
be limited between countries that are
actually see each other as enemies okay
well amy francisco has
mentioned repeatedly importance of
cooperation in space because it's a very
dangerous place in which to operate but
would the americans view the chinese
surely more as competitors in space
rather than potential cooperation
partners do they
yes so they have historically been kept
separate from everything whereas
nasa worked very closely with russia
china has always been on the outside and
um i think there may have been one
analog astronaut mission that had a
taikonaut but other than that there
they just do not work together so that
would be um
interesting to see what what happens in
terms of that um because they i believe
they launched their second module to the
space station
and um yeah they're moving they're
moving very rapidly with that
francisco do you know how china's space
program compares to that of russia
they've launched another uh rocket
recently to the to the tiangong um
and to build the tiangong space station
well yes the chinese
space program came a little bit late we
must remember that the uh the first uh
successful missions to space were from
the soviet union
and then the first satellite the first
space walk the first woman in space etc
etc so it comes from the 1950s the 1960s
and the chinese came only recently very
successfully actually launching very
successful missions to the moon to mars
when they have a
successful landing on mars with a rover
on the back side of the moon as well
they have another rover there
so are now building their own space
station but they came a bit late they're
a bit behind in time but i think they
are making real very very good progress
i think and uh i think which we should
aim in the future to see more
collaboration that's i i i have to
repeat myself again and again no for
francisco you say is china's late to to
to the space race but uh and is it
catching up technologically uh with the
us would that be is that a concern for
the us i know you keep mentioning
cooperation but
there isn't much cooperation between
these two superpowers well no not at the
moment of course and of course
technologically china has less
experience if you like
but if you see the interior of them of
the modern of the new space station of
china is quite remarkable it's very tidy
and very well organized and you see
they're a kind of technology which is
very well thought and very well
designed so i think technologically
i don't know i i won't know i'm not
qualified to to to really put a mark in
why which technological uh uh it has
more advanced but
the um certainly the experience comes in
this in the size of of us russia and
certainly nasa
amy is space exploration and enterprise
that still needs state backing we
mentioned earlier uh axiom we have
spacex we have just bezos blue origin we
have branches branson's
galactic we have a
jared isaac man and three others being
launched into orbit to visit the space
station will this be taken over by
private billionaires or do we still need
spec state um contributions
we will still need state contributions
spacex gets money from nasa for the
seats for the astronauts
and um for other programs so as nasa is
looking to go back to the moon
um it is partnering with a lot of these
companies and there is you know money
involved for them
um
but
nasa's plan is to you know push out
further into the uh solar system so they
are wanting to help these companies you
know set up in low earth orbit so that
there can be
a lot of activity going on there and
then nasa can
divert a lot of its resources to more
deep space but it will still
be a com a partner a customer for these
companies
and pavel does ros cosmos see this as
still see prestige in space exploration
or is it money that matters more to the
russians now could they make could they
profit from this sort of desire for
private exploration of space
well actually the private
companies like spacex they were
competing with russia
and
in space launches and commercial space
launches not only in the
iss
and uh
that's seen as enough actually the price
of putting payloads into orbit has
decreased and russia has seen itself
being pushed out of the commercial
market and ross cosmos losing
their money cows that they were getting
because of the russian budget is of
course much smaller
than the
chinese or the americans and they were
ross cosmos was very much after the end
of the cold war surviving on kind of
earning money and now they have lost a
lot of that capability
and so they're right now talking that
right now their main priority is
supporting the russian forces on the
ground in ukraine sending more uh
military satellites into orbit
increasing the number of military
satellites communications
recon
so they're kind of right now more
militarizing because their commercial uh
part is not really
completely compatible competable
with the new
commercial
american and other
entities that are there on the market
and francisco how do you view the
growing involvement of private
individuals in
space exploration is it to be welcomed
or something that should be done much
more in cooperation with state
institutions well exactly it's a bit of
a mixed uh
idea here of course it is welcome he's
welcome to have more experience and but
at the same time it has to be regulated
you cannot have this anarchy you cannot
have these people i want to do it first
because i have the money to do it it is
not possible we have a very good example
which is the antarctic treaty
the antarctic treaty has a variety of
countries
that are collaborating in on the very
strict regulations and that we have also
the outer space treaty from the united
nations that it is there it hasn't been
implemented properly it hasn't been
enforced properly but all these partners
all these contributors we remember we
have other countries as well we have
india
as well uh coming the
the uae all these countries that have
sent even
spacecraft to mars they have to be
properly regulated uh okay otherwise
it's going to be anarchy and i come home
again to the international collaboration
properly regulated okay we've run out of
time but pavel uh pavel felgenhauer amy
thompson and francisco diego thank you
very much for your contributions and
thank you too for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com and for more
debate go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter we are at aj inside store
from me bernard smith and the entire
team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you